[Music]
on the dish this morning an ancient
south american feast with a husband and
wife team trying to reimagine the modern
restaurant maria rondo was an architect
juan ma calderon a filmmaker they've
taken those artistic skills and
transferred them to food both in the
kitchen and as you'll see
underground
to see what they're up to we traveled to
vermont
for a pachamanca
pachamanca means earthpot
it begins with a pit
rocks are heated to a scolding
temperature while the bounty of meat
potatoes and vegetables are prepped
nearby this is the three kind of meat
that we're gonna use today
pachamancas are a peruvian tradition
going back hundreds of years
but maria rondeau and juan mac calderon
have brought them to vermont with a new
restaurant which doubles as their house
the notion of having a restaurant inside
your own space where you are sharing or
we're asking people or inviting people
to come and share our own table or spend
time in our own kitchen
in that sense it's experimental because
we're not sure where it all leads
esmeralda is the couple's latest project
following the popularity of celeste in
somerville massachusetts esquire named
celeste one of the best new restaurants
in america
eater called it boston's best restaurant
of 2018. it's known for its modern twist
on classic peruvian dishes like ceviche
and lomo saltado
did the success of celeste surprise you
until now every day every day we're
surprised yes
a restaurant was never the plan
rondeau had found success as an
architect calderon was a filmmaker but
they started doing dinner parties on
weekends with calderon showing off the
recipes his mother made him as a boy 4
000 miles away in peru at what point did
you make the decision to make the leap
from doing dinner parties to
we're going to open a restaurant because
the parties get out of control anyway
so we need to move do we need to find a
place
where we cannot disturb the neighbors or
even the kids yeah we had no idea what
we were getting into everybody would say
no that's crazy don't open a restaurant
you have flexibility you can travel but
we were we were actually kind of
yearning to set root a little bit
while celeste is an urban experience
esmeralda is a rural adventure in the
rolling hills of andover about a
four-hour drive from new york city
it's where we watched as the pachamanca
unfolded papas all right potatoes going
first
potatoes followed by lamb pork chicken
vegetables and squash
all placed around the stones in their
own special spot
so now we're nearing the top the last
layer's going to be
getting close to the top it's like
building a stairway to heaven
[Laughter]
once it's topped off with corn and fava
beans and a blend of fresh herbs it's
time to let the earth take over
you have to cover it all up again yeah
here i'll do it all right
go
that's the moment where the stones will
be heated to the point that they can
then be interspersed in the food and
sear it and then it will be covered in
earth and so it becomes a pressure
cooker so it's a combination between
searing with the direct contact and the
vapor and the pressure cooking inside
the cavity
creating deliciousness creating a
pachamanca what is it about the flavor
of the pachamanca that is so distinct
it must be the
the time
the trust
all right guys
we need to
toast to mother earth
okay after the pachamanca is blessed
with booze
it sits for an hour it's always amazed
me the blend of
of peruvian food yeah as the potatoes
they're like at 5000 different kind of
potatoes so we have a lot of
fish and seafood
and we also have food from the mountains
from the amazon so you have all these
altitudes to grow different things and
yeah and everything have a different
flavor
here it is
the unveiling when our feast finally
emerges it's plated and served in all
its earth infused glory chicken
sweet potatoes and potatoes
pork lamb
more potatoes carrots
squash
lima beans
corn and a few sauces
in this one as well all cooked together
as one big happy family yes exactly look
at this gorgeous palette
okay
so is it the moment to try it it is all
right do we say anything special
um
fair enough
oh man
there is nothing about this that doesn't
taste authentic it's very different
there's no other way to describe it than
i have one adjective other than
different all right excellent
so thank you thank you
this is so much fun
just an hour jeff
yeah well i mean it's hot under the
earth there yeah
such a tie to the jerk i mean it's kind
of amazing right and it all gets cooked
to the perfect temperature by the way
we're gonna we're gonna top all this off
you've got a bug in the steam yeah yeah
okay going after our pisco sours nice
these are the pisco sours so it's pisco
lime juice simple syrup and egg white
you mix everything together by shaking
it without ice that makes the foam yeah
then you shake it up again like eight to
ten times and you're ready to serve
cheers cheers
salud we'll get a big hole going outside